est ce qui vous réveille.
Vous ne pouvez rien tenir pour acquis.
Le voyage, pour moi, c'est un peu comme être amoureux,
car soudainement, tous vos sens sont activés.
Soudainement, vous prenez conscience des schémas secrets du monde.
Le seul véritable voyage, comme l'a dit Marcel Proust,
n'est pas d'aller voir de nouveaux paysages,
mais d'avoir d'autres yeux.
Et bien sûr, une fois que vous avez de nouveaux yeux,
même les vieux paysages, même votre maison
deviennent quelque chose de différent.
Beaucoup de gens parmi ceux qui vivent dans un pays qui n'est pas le leur
sont des réfugiés qui n'ont jamais voulu quitter leur maison,
et qui brûlent d'envie de rentrer chez eux.
Mais pour les chanceux parmi nous,
je crois que l'ère de la mobilité nous apporte de nouvelles possibilités exaltantes.
Assurément, quand je voyage,
surtout dans les grandes villes du monde,
la personne type que je rencontre ces temps-ci
sera, disons, une jeune femme à moitié coréenne et à moitié allemande
qui vit à Paris.
Et dès qu'elle rencontre un jeune homme
moitié thaï, moitié canadien venu d’Édimbourg,
elle voit en lui un semblable.
Elle réalise qu'elle a sans doute bien plus de choses en commun avec lui
qu'avec quelqu'un qui serait complètement coréen ou complètement allemand.
Donc ils deviennent amis. Ils tombent amoureux.
Ils s'installent à New York City.
(Rires)
Ou à Édimbourg.
Et la petite fille qui naît de leur union
bien sûr ne sera ni coréenne, ni allemande,
ni française, ni thaï, ni écossaise, ni canadienne,
ni même américaine, mais un merveilleux
mélange en perpétuelle évolution de tous ces endroits.
Et potentiellement, tout dans la manière
dont cette jeune femme rêve du monde,
écrit sur le monde, pense du monde,
pourrait être quelque chose de différent,
parce que c'est issu de ce mélange des cultures
presque sans précédent.
L'endroit d'où vous venez est aujourd'hui bien moins important
que celui où vous allez.
De plus en plus d'entre nous ont leurs racines dans le futur
ou dans le présent autant que dans le passé.
Et nous savons qu'être chez soi, ce n'est pas seulement
être là où, par hasard, vous êtes né.
C'est être là où vous devenez vous-même.
Et cependant,
il y a un énorme problème avec le mouvement,
et c'est qu'il est vraiment difficile de trouver ses repères
quand on est en plein ciel.
Il y a quelques années, j'ai remarqué que j'avais accumulé
un million de miles rien que chez United Airlines.
Vous connaissez tous ce système fou,
passez six jours en enfer, et le septième est gratuit.
(Rires)
Et j'ai commencé à penser que vraiment,
le mouvement ne vaut que le sentiment de calme
que vous pouvez y apporter pour le mettre en perspective.
Et huit mois après l'incendie de ma maison,
j'ai rencontré par hasard un ami qui enseignait dans un lycée du coin,
et il m'a dit : « J'ai l'endroit parfait pour toi. »
J'ai répondu : « Vraiment ? » Je suis toujours un peu sceptique
quand des gens me disent des choses comme ça.
« Non, sérieusement », a-t-il continué,
« c'est seulement à trois heures d'ici en voiture,
et ce n'est pas très cher,
et ça ne ressemble sans doute à aucun des endroits où tu as vécu auparavant. »
« Hmm. » Je commençais à être légèrement intrigué. « Qu'est-ce que c'est ? »
« Eh bien -- » Là mon ami a commencé à bafouiller --
« Eh bien en fait, c'est un ermitage catholique. »
C'était la mauvaise réponse.
J'avais passé 15 ans dans des écoles anglicanes,
donc j'avais eu assez d'hymnes et de croix pour une vie entière.
Pour plusieurs vies, en réalité.
Mais mon ami m'a assuré qu'il n'était pas catholique,
pas plus que la majorité de ses étudiants,
mais qu'il y emmenait ses classes chaque printemps.
Et d'après lui, même le garçon Californien de 15 ans
le plus agité, distrait, rempli de testostérone
n'avait qu'à passer trois jours en silence
et quelque chose en lui se calmait et se libérait.
Il se trouvait lui-même.
Et j'ai pensé : « Quelque chose qui fonctionne pour un garçon de 15 ans
devrait fonctionner pour moi. »
Je suis donc monté en voiture, et j'ai conduit trois heures vers le nord
le long de la côte,
et les routes sont devenues de plus en plus vides et de plus en plus étroites,
et puis j'ai tourné dans un chemin encore plus étroit,
à peine pavé, qui serpentait pendant trois kilomètres
jusqu'au sommet d'une montagne.
Et quand je suis sorti de ma voiture,
le vent soufflait.
L'endroit était absolument silencieux,
mais le silence n'était pas une absence de bruit.
C'était plutôt une présence d'une sorte d'énergie ou d'accélération.
Et à mes pieds il y avait la surface immense, calme et bleue
de l'Océan Pacifique.
Tout autour de moi, il y avait 300 hectares d'arbustes secs et sauvages.
Et je suis allé dans la pièce où je devais dormir.
Petite, mais extrêmement confortable,
il y avait un lit et une chaise à balance
et un long bureau, et une baie vitrée encore plus longue
donnant sur un petit jardin privé entouré de murs,
et derrière plus de 300 mètres d'herbe de la pampa dorée
courant jusqu'à la mer.
Et je me suis assis, et j'ai commencé à écrire,
et j'ai écrit, et écrit,
alors que j'étais venu en fait pour fuir mon bureau.
Et quand je me suis levé, il s'était passé 4 heures.
La nuit était tombée,
et je suis sortie sous cette immense salière renversée pleine d'étoiles
et je pouvais voir les feux de voitures
disparaissant derrière les caps 20 kilomètres au sud.
Et j'avais vraiment l'impression que mes soucis du jour précédent
étaient en train de disparaître.
Et le jour suivant, quand je me suis réveillé,
en l'absence de téléphones, de télévisions et d'ordinateurs portables,
les jours semblaient s'étirer et durer mille heures.
C'était vraiment toute la liberté que je connais quand je voyage,
mais ça me donnait aussi profondément l'impression de rentrer chez moi.
Et je ne suis pas religieux,
donc je ne suis pas allé aux offices.
Je n'ai pas consulté les moines pour leur demander conseil.
Je me suis juste promené le long de la route du monastère
et j'ai envoyé des cartes postales à ceux que j'aime.
J'ai regardé les nuages,
et j'ai fait ce qui d'habitude est pour moi le plus difficile à faire,
c'est-à-dire rien du tout.
Et j'ai commencé à revenir à cet endroit,
et j'ai remarqué que j'y faisais mon travail le plus important
de manière invisible, rien qu'en restant calmement assis,
et j'ai certainement pris mes décisions les plus critiques
comme je ne pouvais jamais le faire quand je courais
entre mon dernier e-mail et mon prochain rendez-vous.
Et j'ai commencé à penser que quelque chose en moi
avait vraiment eu besoin de calme,
mais bien sûr je n'avais pas pu l'entendre,
puisque je courais dans tous les sens.
J'étais comme un fou qui se met un bandeau sur les yeux
et se plaint ensuite de ne rien voir.
Et je me suis souvenu de cette magnifique citation
que j'avais apprise enfant, de Sénèque,
dans laquelle il dit : « L'homme pauvre,
ce n'est pas celui qui n'a rien, c'est celui qui désire plus. »
Et bien sûr, je ne suis pas en train de suggérer
que vous alliez dans un monastère.
Ce n'est pas la question.
Mais je crois vraiment que c'est seulement en arrêtant le mouvement
que l'on peut définir une direction.
Et c'est seulement en sortant de sa vie et du monde
que l'on peut voir ce que l'on chérit le plus
et trouver un « chez soi ».
Et j'ai remarqué qu'aujourd'hui, beaucoup de gens
prennent des mesures conscientes pour rester assis calmement pendant 30 minutes
chaque matin, juste pour se détendre
dans un coin de la pièce sans sans leurs appareils,
ou vont courir chaque matin,
ou laissent leurs téléphones derrière eux
quand ils s'apprêtent à avoir une longue conversation avec un ami.
Le mouvement est un privilège fantastique,
et il nous permet de faire tant de choses que nos grands-parents
n'auraient jamais pu rêver de faire.
Mais le mouvement, finalement,
n'a de signification que si on a une maison où rentrer.
Et une maison, finalement, ce n'est bien sûr
pas seulement l'endroit où on dort.
C'est l'endroit où on est.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)